liebe mitbürgerinnen liebe mitbürger das
corona virus verändert zur zeit das
leben in unserem land dramatisch
unsere vorstellung von normalität von
öffentlichem leben von sozialem
miteinander
all das wird auf die probe gestellt wie
nie zuvor
millionen von ihnen können nicht zur
arbeit
ihre kinder können nicht zur schule oder
in die kita theater und kinos und
geschäfte sind geschlossen und was
vielleicht das schwerste ist uns allen
fehlen die begegnung die sonst
selbstverständlich sind natürlich ist
jeder von uns in solch einer situation
voller fragen und voller sorgen wie es
weitergeht
ich wende mich heute auf diesem
ungewöhnlichen weg an sie weil ich ihnen
sagen will was mich als bundeskanzlerin
und alle meine kollegen in der
bundesregierung in dieser situation
leitet das gehört zu einer offenen
demokratie dass wir die politischen
entscheidungen auch transparent machen
und erläutern dass wir unser handeln
möglichst gut begründen und
kommunizieren damit es nachvollziehbar
wird
ich glaube fest daran dass wir diese
aufgabe bestehen wenn wirklich alle
bürgerinnen und bürger sie als ihre
aufgabe begreifen
deswegen lassen sie mich sagen es ist
ernst nehmen sie es auch ernst seit der
deutschen einheit
nein seit dem zweiten weltkrieg gab es
keine herausforderung an unser land mehr
bei der es so sehr auf unser gemeinsames
solidarisches handeln ankommt ich möchte
ihnen erklären wo wir aktuell stehen in
der epidemie was die bundesregierung und
die staatlichen ebenen tun um alle in
unserer gemeinschaft zu schützen und den
ökonomischen sozialen kulturellen
schaden zu begrenzen
aber ich möchte ihnen auch vermitteln
warum ist sie dafür braucht und was
jeder und jede einzelne dazu beitragen
kann
zur epidemie und alles was sie ihnen
dazu sage kommt aus den ständigen
beratungen der bundesregierung mit den
experten disco
koch instituts und anderen
wissenschaftlern und virologen es wird
weltweit unter hochdruck geforscht aber
noch gibt es weder eine therapie ging
das corona virus noch einen impfstoff
solange das so ist gibt es nur eines und
das ist die richtschnur all unseren
handelns die ausbreitung des virus zu
verlangsamen sie über die monate zu
strecken und so zeit zu gewinnen zeit
damit die forschung ein medikament und
einen impfstoff entwickeln kann aber vor
allem auch zeit damit diejenigen die
erkrankten bestmöglich versorgt werden
können deutschland hat ein exzellentes
gesundheitssystem vielleicht eines der
besten der welt
das kann uns zuversicht geben aber auch
unsere krankenhäuser wären völlig
überfordert wenn in kürzester zeit zu
viele patienten eingeliefert würden die
einen schweren verlauf der korona
infektion erleiden
das sind nicht einfach abstrakte zahlen
in einer statistik sondern das ist ein
vater oder großvater eine mutter oder
großmutter eine partnerin oder partner
es sind menschen und wir sind eine
gemeinschaft in der jedes leben und
jeder mensch zählt ich möchte mich bei
dieser gelegenheit zu allererst an alle
wenden die als ärzte oder ärztin im
pflegedienst oder in einer sonstigen
funktion in unseren krankenhäusern und
überhaupt im gesundheitswesen arbeiten
sie stehen für uns in diesem kampf in
der vordersten linie
sie sehen als erste die kranken und wie
schwer manche verläufe der infektion
sind und jeden tag gehen sie aufs neue
an ihrer arbeit und sind für die
menschen da was sie leisten ist gewaltig
und ich danke ihnen von ganzem herzen
dafür also es geht darum das virus auf
seinem weg durch deutschland zu
verlangsamen
und dabei müssen wir das ist ex
essentiell auf eines setzen das
öffentliche leben so weit es geht
herunterzufahren
natürlich mit vernunft und augenmaß denn
der staat wird weiter funktionieren die
versorgung wird selbstverständlich
weiter gesichert sein und wir wollen so
viel wirtschaftlicher tätigkeit wie
möglich bewahren
aber alles was menschen gefährden könnte
alles was dem einzelnen aber auch der
gemeinschaft schaden könnte das müssen
wir jetzt reduzieren
wir müssen das risiko dass der eine den
anderen ansteckt so begrenzen wie wir
nur können
ich weiß wie dramatisch schon jetzt die
einschränkungen sind keine
veranstaltungen mehr keine messen keine
konzerte und vorerst auch keine schule
mehr keine universität kein kindergarten
kein spiel auf einem spielplatz
ich weiß wie hart die schließung auf die
sich bund und länder geeinigt haben in
unser leben und auch unser
demokratisches selbstverständnis
eingreifen
es sind einschränkungen wie es sie in
der bundesrepublik noch nie gab
lassen sie mich versichern für jemanden
wie mich für die reise und
bewegungsfreiheit ein schwer erkämpftes
recht waren sind solche einschränkungen
nur in der absoluten notwendigkeit zu
rechtfertigen
sie sollten in einer demokratie nie
leichtfertig und nur temporär
beschlossen werden
aber sie sind im moment unverzichtbar um
leben zu retten
deswegen sind seit anfang der woche die
verschärften grenzkontrollen und
einreisebeschränkungen zu einigen
unserer wichtigsten nachbarländer in
kraft für die wirtschaft die großen
unternehmen genau wie die kleinen
betriebe für geschäfte restaurants
freiberufler ist es jetzt schon sehr
schwer
und die nächsten wochen werden noch
schwerer ich versichere ihnen die
bundesregierung tut alles was sie kann
um die wirtschaftlichen auswirkungen
abzufedern und vor allem um
arbeitsplätze zu bewahren
wir können und werden alles einsetzen
was es braucht um unseren unternehmen
und arbeitnehmer
durch diese schwere prüfung zu helfen
und alle können sich darauf verlassen
dass die lebensmittelversorgung
jederzeit gesichert ist und wenn regale
ein tag mal leer geräumt sind zu werden
sie nachgefüllt jedem der in den
supermärkten unterwegs ist möchte ich
sagen vorratshaltung ist sinnvoll war es
im übrigen immer schon aber mit maß
hamstern als wäre es nie wieder etwas
geben ist sinnlos und letztlich
vollkommen unsolidarisch und lassen sie
mich auch hier dank aussprechen an
menschen den zu selten gedankt wird wer
in diesen tagen an einer supermarktkasse
sitzt oder regale befüllt der macht
einen der schwersten jobs die es zur
zeit gibt danke dass sie da sind für
ihre mitbürger und buchstäblich den
laden am laufen halten jetzt zu dem was
mir heute das dringendste ist alle
staatlichen maßnahmen gingen ins leere
wenn wir nicht das wirksamste mittel
gegen die zu schnelle ausbreitung des
virus einsetzen würden und das sind wir
selbst sowie unterschiedslos jeder von
uns von dem virus betroffen sein kann
so muss jetzt auch jede und jeder helfen
zuallererst in dem der ernst nehmen
worum es heute geht nicht in panik
verfallen aber auch nicht einen moment
denken auf ihn oder sie komme es doch
nicht wirklich an
niemand ist verzichtbar alle 10
es braucht unser aller anstrengung das
ist was eine epidemie uns zeigt wie
verwundbar wir alle sind wie abhängig
von den rücksichtsvollen verhalten
anderer aber damit eben auch wie wir
durch gemeinsames handeln uns schützen
und gegenseitig stärken können es kommt
auf jeden an
wir sind nicht verdammt die ausbreitung
des virus passiv hinzunehmen wir haben
einen mittel dagegen
wir müssen aus rücksicht voneinander
abstand halten
der rat der virologen ist ja eindeutig
kein handschlag mehr gründlich und oft
die hände waschen
mindestens eineinhalb meter abstand zum
nächsten und am besten kaum noch
kontakte zu den ganz alten weil sie eben
besonders gefährdet sind
ich weiß wie schwer das ist was da von
uns verlangt wird wir möchten gerade in
zeiten der not einander nah sein
wir kennen zuwendung als körperliche
nähe oder berührung
doch im augenblick ist leider das
gegenteil richtig
das müssen wir wirklich alle begreifen
im moment ist nur abstand ausdruck von
fürsorge der gut gemeinte besuch die
reise die nicht hätte sein müssen das
alles kann ansteckung bedeuten und
sollte jetzt wirklich nicht mehr
stattfinden es hat seinen grund warum
die experten sagen großeltern und enkel
sollten nicht zusammenkommen
wer unnötige begegnungen vermeidet hilft
allen die sich in den krankenhäusern um
täglich mehr fälle kümmern müssen
so retten wir leben das wird für viele
schwer und auch darauf wird es ankommen
niemanden allein zu lassen sich um die
zu kümmern die zuspruch und zuversicht
brauchen wir werden als familien und als
gesellschaft andere formen finden
einander beizustehen
schon jetzt gibt es viele kreative form
die dem virus und seinen sozialen folgen
trotzen
schon jetzt gibt es enkel die ihren
großeltern einen podcast aufnehmen damit
sie nicht einsam sind wir alle müssen
wege finden um zuneigung und
freundschaft zu zeigen
skype telefonate mails und vielleicht
mal wieder briefe schreiben die post
wird ja ausgeliefert man hört jetzt von
wunderbaren beispielen von
nachbarschaftshilfe für die älteren die
nicht selbst zum einkaufen gehen können
ich bin sicher da geht noch viel mehr
und wir werden als gemeinschaft zeigen
dass wir einander nicht allein lassen
ich appelliere an sie halten sie sich an
die regeln
die nun für die nächste zeit gelten wir
werden als regierung stets neu prüfen
was sich wieder korrigieren lässt
aber auch was für möglich noch nötig ist
dies ist eine dynamische situation und
wir werden in ihr lernfähig bleiben
um jederzeit umdenken und mit anderen
instrumenten reagieren zu können
auch das werden wir dann erklären
deswegen bitte ich sie glauben sie
keinen gerüchten sondern nur den
offiziellen mitteilungen die wir immer
auch in viele sprachen übersetzen lassen
wir sind eine demokratie wir leben nicht
von zwang sondern von geteiltem wissen
und mitwirkung
dies ist eine historische aufgabe und
sie ist nur gemeinsam zu bewältigen
dass wir diese krise überwinden werden
dessen bin ich vollkommen sicher aber
wie hoch werden die opfer seien wie
viele geliebte menschen werden wir
verlieren wir haben es zu einem großen
teil selbst in der hand wir können jetzt
entschlossen alle miteinander reagieren
wir können die aktuellen einschränkungen
annehmen und einander beistehen
diese situation ist ernst und sie ist
offen
das heißt es wird nicht nur aber auch
davon abhängen wie diszipliniert jeder
und jede die regeln befolgt und umsetzt
wir müssen auch wenn wir so etwas noch
nie erlebt haben zeigen dass wir
herzlich und vernünftig handeln und so
leben retten
es kommt ohne ausnahme auf jeden
einzelnen und damit auf uns alle an
passen sie gut auf sich und auf ihre
liebsten auf ich danke ihnen